mesdames et messieurs bonjour encore
quelques heures avant de dire adieu à
et puis vivre en 1979 pour lequel nous
allons échanger des millions de voeux et
souhait sincère des voeux frileux pour
les habitants du nord et des souhaits
qui soufflent le chaud pour ceux qui
résident dans le sud car étrangement en
ce jour de la saint sylvestre
la france est coupée en deux sur le plan
des températures quant à paris laurent
broomhead vaste un véritable déluge
jean-louis depuis hier soir je crois
qu'il est tombé des tonnes d'eau sur
paris rendant la circulation difficile
même les voies sur berge à paris ont dû
être inondées et coupées en fait tu
laves le déluge s'est produit sur toute
une bande qui sépare donc comme vous le
disiez très bien le nord de la sud au
nord bien d'abord il ya beaucoup de
neige sur la grande-bretagne l'ecosse
était complètement paralysé longue
servier ce matin avec 10 cm de neige et
les aéroports heathrow et gatwick ont
été coupées neige aussi sur le réseau
routier français dans le nord le
pas-de-calais et la somme ça c'est au
nord et plus au sud
beaucoup de pluies de la tempête le port
de bordeaux a été fermé parce qu'elles
avaient décru de huit mètres et
noirmoutier lui 250 hectares inondés
voit la situation actuelle qui n'est pas
très gai alors qu'est-ce qui va
l'emporter
pour demain le froid ou le doubs et bien
c'est le froid qui va progressivement
l'emporter aujourd'hui est bien le froid
va descendre jusqu'aux charente le
bassin parisien et les ardennes avec des
nuages beaucoup de neige et du vent du
nord au sud donc un ton toujours doux
avec des averses violentes et puis quand
même des éclaircies et des plus en
montagne jusqu'à 10 800 mètres
différence de température et bien 0
degrés au nord où matt simmons dans la
journée et au sud en revanche près de la
méditerranée
15 degrés vous savez laurent vous
connaissez le dicton on
noël au balcon et pâques aux tisons l'a
fait très doux à noël ça veut dire après
froid pâques
eh bien je crois pouvoir vous dire que
nous en fait si vous voulez vraiment
tendre pas dès maintenant je vous
propose plutôt de prendre une pièce de
monnaie et puis de tire au sort vous
aurez plus de chance je propose comme de
vous donner le temps de demain sur
lequel lui j'ai quand même un peu plus
d'espoir de vous donner la vérité
beaucoup de neige dans l'est du pays et
le froid cette fois ci sur l'ensemble du
pays il fera froid entre -5 et -10
degrés au lever du jour sur le nord la
normandie la champagne les ardennes les
températures ne monteront pas au dessus
de zéro degré ou cinq dans la journée
voila voila merci l'or alors compte à
rebours h - 10h pour le réveillon les
libations
bref la grande bouffe avec et c'est
moins drôle en perspective la gueule de
bois de demain n'est ce pas docteur
alors ces troubles s'est essentiellement
les maux de tête des ventes douleurs
dans le ventre
un état nauséeux et parfois des
vomissements et enfin une plus ou moins
grande fatigue
par des huîtres vivre à part des
poissons fumés divers et variés on
continuera par une volaille riesling et
on terminera par des fromages ses petits
fours accompagnée de champagne nature
voilà vous avez un devoir
oui à boire mariner avec une bonne bière
très bon cru de l'est c'est un staff est
là reste au chaud c'est un verre à peu
près d'un demi d'admis d'un demi-litre
enfin 54 et on le boit c'est un alcool
blanc alors tu es variable c'est la
prune séduit c'est ce qu'on veut
finalement 1 à col blanc l'arrestation a
fallu matin dans la botte de boire à
sochaux c'est bon je crois qu'aucun de
ces trucs mais l'efficacité démontrée et
à mon avis ils sont aussi nuitées en
matière de médicaments
il faut en prendre vraiment le moins
possible et se limitaient par exemple
lorsque les maux de tête sont trop peu
inconfortable à des antalgiques tout à
fait mineurs de préférence d'ailleurs
nous contenons pas d'aspirine
rien non plus
vous n'y croyez pas c'est trop
voilà il ya le choix le président de la
république présentera ses voeux aux
français ce soir 20h à la télévision
monsieur giscard d'estaing est rentré la
nuit dernière du gabon où il a séjourné
pendant une semaine avec sa famille le
chef de l'état a eu hier un entretien
politique avec le président gabonais
omar bongo
il a révélé que les ministres des
finances de la zone franc se réuniront à
paris fin janvier pour parler du système
monétaire européen
et puis nouveaux affrontements
aujourd'hui en iran notamment dans la
ville sainte de machhad où l'on a compté
41 morts hier
à téhéran on murmure de plus en plus que
le chat pourrait quitter le pays afin de
se reposer à l'étranger les à washington
on ajoute que le souverain ne partira
pas tant que monsieur bakhtiar le
premier ministre désigné n'aura pas
former son gouvernement
l'ayatollah khomeiny dans une interview
au sunday telegraph indique clairement
que les bus de ces manifestations et
d'entraîner la chute du shah et que si
ça ne suffit pas eh bien il faudra
prendre les armes
le roi du maroc hassan ii et le
président boumédiène devaient se
rencontrer en secret à bruxelles si le
chef de l'état algérien n'était pas
tombé malade
c'est une révélation faite par hassan ii
à notre confrère de france inter edouard
sabliers et puis aux états unis
conclusions d'une commission
parlementaire
deux hommes ont participé à l'assassinât
du président kennedy de tueurs et quatre
coups de feu ont été tirés après deux
ans d'enquêté cette commission se dit
certaines de ces révélations à 95% en
france collision hier soir entre un
train de voyageurs et un train de
marchandises à orly un conducteur et un
voyageur ont été tués le maniaque de
l'oise
les enquêteurs se disent persuadés qu'il
pourrait être un policier ou un gendarme
enfin à l'opéra de paris les machinistes
qui avait assuré hier soir la
représentation du lac des cygnes ont
repris leur mouvement de grève
le spectacle de ce soir sera représentée
sans décor indique la direction de
l'opéra et nous en arrivons à notre page
spectacle qui traite à la fois de danse
et de théâtre avec un thème commun notre
dame de paris l'oeuvre de victor hugo a
inspiré beaucoup de créateurs des
cinéastes certes mais aussi des
dramaturges et vous allez le voir des
corps ekra a paris il ya trois
notre-dame lavrec
la scène puis deux autres voici
esmeralda au palais des congrès russe
ses toiles du ballet kirov elle
s'appelle olga chico va
on palais des sports l'autre esmeralda
s'appelle anne fontaine quasimodo gérard
boucard on dans le spectacle de robert
hossein
version chorégraphique quasiment dos
dansé par sergei béret genou y a un peu
perdu sa bosse
le
m
et
oui
et puis voici frollo l'incarnation du
mal sur scène barbus c'est jean pierre
bernard
et dans le ballet de roland petit c'est
guennadi baba nine habillée très haute
couture mais toujours aussi méchant
ici
notre lettre ouverte à l'an 2000 en ce
31 décembre ne peut que concerner les
festivités de ce soir le réveillon tous
vos achats sont faits les huîtres le
boudin blanc le foie gras mais avez vous
pensé au pain manger le bon pain doré
d'autrefois
quel délice cette lettre est donc écrite
par le boulanger le plus célèbre de
paris monsieur poilâne un homme qui
croit à ce qu'il crée c'est tout de même
bien agréable pour moi en tant que
boulanger le pain de l'an 2000 c'est
curieux mais c'est le pain de grands
patins je vais vous dire je ne suis
surtout pas un réactionnaire ou un
monsieur qui est tourné vers le passé
c'est pas parce que j'ai bloqué
l'évolution technique dans l'entreprise
de boulangerie que je suis contre le
progrès bien au contraire
voyez vous si si vous présentez un
ordinateur qui soit assez complexe qui
soit assez élaborés pour faire du pain
un pas qu'il soit parfait je vous dirais
oui boucherait pourrait sang pour sang
la vie malheureusement le problème c'est
que tous les aménagements techniques qui
ont été faits dans mon secteur des idées
dans la boulangerie ont été à linverse
dans la qualité du pain alors c'est pour
ça je vous disais pour moi le pain blanc
de 800 grand-papa le jeu vif et en tout
à fait extraordinaire en tant que
boulanger
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir un père qui
m'a transmis une technique une technique
ancestrale qui a complètement été perdu
de vue est très technique était la
technique des boulangers de la fin du
jeudi dernier du début de ce siècle
alors ce qui était extraordinaire c'est
que je n'utilise pas de four
à vapeur je n'utilise pas de produits
d'améliorer les sit-in d'acide
ascorbique de tout l'arsenal des
améliorants à la fois alimentaire et
techniques qui sont utilisés en
boulangerie et j'arrive quand même je
paye mon percepteur et je fais face aux
charges de personnel alors ça quand même
c'est quand même assez extraordinaire
j'utilise une farine l'écrasé à la meule
c'est par certains côtés du point de vue
scientifique s'était fait mal expliqué
la différence entre la farine de meule
et latrines de cylindres cependant nous
avons fait des expériences qu'ils
laissent apparaître une différence elle
est de nature des choses qui peut être
échappé à la finesse de l'analyse
voyez-vous quand en gastronomie en
cuisine ou plus spécialement vous faites
une purée au pilon une purée au mixeur
vous avez deux purs et qui sont
différentes et bien la farine de meule
c'est pas aussi flagrant mais il ya
quelque chose de différent et vous sont
des petites choses comme ça qui mis bout
à bout je vous rappelle arrive à faire
un produit qui est vraiment différent
pour l'instant vous êtes sûr de votre
farine vers l'an 2000
est ce que vous êtes sûr de trouver
encore de la base farine pour faire
maintenant moi je suis sûr qu'en l'an
2000 où seul en 2000 c'est pas si loin
que ça on trouvera du blé c'est pas
compliqué et puis je vais vous dire je
préfère est né dans un pays où les du
blé que du pétrole
j'utilise 20 jours qui est chauffé au
bois
alors évidemment de le boire c'est un
problème pour trouver du bois dans paris
actuellement parce que c'est pas c'est
pas bien facile et plus souvent je suis
obligé de le transformer avant
chiffonniers parce qu'il faut trouver du
bois mais
j'utilise quand même deux ministères de
bois par an et je faisais le calcul
justement ces jours ci j'ai quand même
économie deux millions de litres de
fioul depuis que nous chauffons au
revoir cette façon là un four ancien
c'est en gros c'est une
c'est une voûte avec une sole à dire de
laquelle cuit du pain 7 vous et ce sol
celle du réfractaire
vous avez environ 25 tonnes de briques
réfractaires qui sont à l'intérieur
la caractéristique de cette brique
réfractaire c'est de ponctionner
d'humidité
c'est à dire ces deux d'extirper toutes
les matières humide les matières
volatiles qui sont à l'intérieur du pain
et quand ces pins qui sont à l'intérieur
reçoivent cette agression est bien toute
l'humidité pas alors évidemment que le
pain pèse moins lourd et accepte une
moins value pour le boulanger mais tous
les parfums qui sont enfermés à
l'intérieur du pain qui sont et qui
migrent par la croûte arrive être
distillée par la route et si ce qui
contribue à donner du parfum ou pas mais
où j'ai fait l'expérience de faire
griller d'héparine sur une plaque de
métal et bien elles n'ont pas du tout le
même goût que dans son encrier sur une
miche de pain lieu d'un problème
d'osmose entre les parfums alors ce sont
des petites choses tout ça mais mis bout
à bout d'un an on arrive à faire un
produit qui est dénaturé qui n'apportent
plus ce qu'on peut appeler de
satisfaction digestives ou même
gastronomique du point de vue des outils
j'utilise un paletot russe indépendant
en osier comme ça et bien c'est panneton
en osier permettre est un matériau
naturel permettent l'arrivée de l'air
dans le fond il ya de la farine pour
éviter de la pâte colle et cette farine
col très légèrement avec la pâte
l'humidité là bas et il ya une
population qui vit la nand et mycélium
déferrement qui font que ça ans lance la
flore du fournil et voyez-vous cet outil
j'y tiens beaucoup parce que et c'est ce
qui permet au pain et au fournil en
gerra d'entretenir sa flore et
les antilles qui partiront avec 20 g je
crois pas donc j'y vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que d'abord c'est trop
cher un pain au japon coûte actuellement
250 francs nouveau 25000 anciens c'est
vrai même très cher
oui je le fais mais ça reste si vous
voulez réservé à une élite et comme j'en
envoie aussi aux états unis et dans les
pays arabes mais ça reste toujours ciblé
les petites quantités c'est vraiment
anecdotique on peut pas parler
d'industrie de dupin expédiés par avion
par contre ce que je crois c'est à la
technique qu'ils voulaient qu'ils
pourraient être transmises alors à des
japonais des chinois des américains où
elle drame saint louis ce que vous
croyez qu'en l'an 2000
vous trouverez encore des ouvriers pour
travailler comme ça oui j'en suis sûr
j'en suis sûr parce que ça exige en
réalité peut-être pas plus de travail
ce que ça y est j exige de plus c'est du
soin alors cibler les gens maintenant
actuellement je les vois je vois les
gens qui travaillent avec les quatre
jeux on vit ensemble sont acquis à la
notion d' apporter plus de soin à leur
travail c'est curieux parce que c'est un
phénomène qui se fait sentir pas depuis
très longtemps mais je crois que d'une
façon générale les gens se réalise en
apportant plus de soin à leur métier
alors je crois pour répondre aux
questions qu a aucun problème on
trouvera les bourbes mon boulanger en en
branle en 2000
est ce qu'ils ont pensé qu'en l'an 2000
le paysage de la boulangerie ne sera pas
ou d'un côté la boulangerie industrielle
et d'un autre côté il des gens comme
vous mais là encore c'est il n'arrive
jamais ce que l'on croit en 1960 je me
souviens on disait vous savez maintenant
la boulangerie artisanale c'est quelque
chose qui est voué à un échec potentiel
il n'y aurait que des juges qui
n'atteint pas du tout lisez les journaux
il ya actuellement une usine qui
licencient huit mille ouvriers
boulangers en angleterre c'est un
phénomène je suis persuadé que louvre le
le boulanger du coin de la rue à la
condition qu'ils qui se prennent pas
pour un pharmacien et sera un monsieur
un des racines à bhl ce sera en plus de
ça un monsieur qui sera très important
du point de vue de l'homogénéité d'un
village même dans une grande ville c'est
qu'il ya plusieurs le village et ça sera
un monsieur très importants de ce point
de vue et je suis persuadé que ça fera
partie de ces gens qui jouent un rôle
sur le plan social et surtout sur le
plan même gastronomique et santé
indispensables et ces gens là sont des
uns des racines je vous répète à la
condition et qui n'est pas le complexe
du pharmacien voit la fin de ce journal
de la mi-journée prochaine édition à 20
heures aussitôt après les voeux du
président de la république
toute la rédaction d'antenne 2 vous
souhaite un très bon après midi
oui